organic shapes and glistening colors
these chairs and lamps are made from
methacrylate usually used to make
industrial products such as car
reflectors Yakupov or genie prefers to
make unique pieces out of it a dream
he's had since childhood when he
discovered the material in his father's
factory everything started from from a
day in which I was a little little boy
and I saw from the nose of this machine
coming out this material for the first
time and it was like a seam in my in my
brain in my imagination that slowly
slowly grow until the moment that I I
decided to change my life and to you
know to dedicate my career to using this
material the 48 year old has a studio in
Milan where he works on prototypes with
his team to make the pieces the granules
have to be melted at a temperature above
300 degrees Celsius then color is added
and the material is molded into shape
yes of course it is dangerous because
the material is very hot and you have
few seconds to move it and there is no
stamp and or anything so everything is
already done by hand Giacomo Puccini's
latest creation is the Jill Deppe chair
he designed it for the Italian high-end
furniture company aedra he has this name
because it's dedicated to GW Rd the
director of internal magazine which is
like second mom for me more or less it's
a fantastic woman she's the woman that
she invented the Salone del Mobile so
together we did most of 20 installation
from snakes of 64 metre long or you know
you'd really crazy project together
Puccini's work has been shown in dozens
of museums and galleries around the
world and every year he exhibits at the
Milan Furniture Fair this installation
was created for the 2012 for a solo
leader this installation at the Basilica
de Sant Ambrogio was entitled symbols
for genie also works together with
international architects and designs the
interiors of hotels museums and private
homes work I feel like to be a child and
I think that this is the right attitude
to develop any project so I play with
this material and imagining my world
from light to chair to table to
everything and all of it made from a
material that was originally only meant
for manufacturing car parts